I love massively multiplayer
role-playing games
I love Elder Scrolls games and I love
exploring huge fantasy worlds yet it was
weird over the last year or so the Elder
Scrolls online didn't get me excited it
looked old and it played old this past
weekend I got to play a few dozen hours
of it I still think it feels old and
it's clearly torn between two worlds the
world of the MMO and the world of Elder
Scrolls but there's just enough here to
make me look forward to what the final
release will have to offer what drew me
in was the world yes it's a world many
of us already know but the Elder Scrolls
online uses that familiarity to its
advantage easing back on the user
interface and allowing Tamriel to fill
the screen by default you don't see
names hovering over the heads of your
fellow players and the hotbar containing
your attack icons disappears when you're
not engaged in combat as you stroll
about the streets of Daggerfall the
compass at the top of the screen and a
brief quest description are your only
on-screen guides this is where the game
excels the series high fantasy tone is
front and center creepy graveyards and
tranquil meadows both have their unique
kind of beauty this is a place I want to
be as I played however it didn't take me
long to see the downside of the game's
focus on immersion and it didn't help
that the group of folks playing was
relatively small I was approaching the
Elder Scrolls online like Skyrim or
Oblivion as a solo adventure I
occasionally noticed other players but
there was no reason to interact with
them so I had to ask myself does this
game need to be online at all I'm sure
it's too soon to know however because I
was a lone adventurer it didn't take
long for me to notice that next to say
Skyrim the Elder Scrolls online wasn't
stacking up the usual Elder Scrolls
invitation to go anywhere and do
anything has been stifled a bit
instead sending you down a path more
akin to other online RPGs nevertheless I
enjoyed my questing time Bethesda has
always done a great job of taking
typical RPG duties and giving them good
context so that you don't feel like
you're repeating the same activities
over and over again when villagers were
burnt out of their homes I went in
search of stray victims in need of
assistance when I was transported to the
Past I discovered the origins of a
racial conflict that had present-day
implications and in many of those cases
I had choices on how to proceed for
example I could interrogate prisoners so
that they would divulge the information
I required or I could order the guards
to slit their throats and then compel
the victims spirits to spill their
ghostly guts of course a lot of these
quests required that I slash up bandits
and wolves with daggers or fling fire at
them I liked that the Elder Scrolls
online provides so much flexibility in
how you develop your character
sadly the clunky combat just doesn't
measure up the stiff animations and
seemingly random hit boxes make for a
milquetoast skirmishes but you know I
had fun in spite of the obvious identity
issues in the bland action fantasy
ambience and the varied quests kept me
absorbed the question is whether the
enjoyment can last and I'm not sure that
the Elder Scrolls online can properly
combine online adventuring and Elder
Scrolls world building without making
both aspects of the game feel incomplete
I feel mildly disappointed but I leave
it up to you
you